d'ailleurs steve gaines et sa copine
readers so now we are in france est liée
au laminoir femmes et diagnostics ce
chapitre 3 la surprise de la lumière
dans la maison a dit sylvie je n'arrive
pas à y croire
s'il y a suivi le chemin qui menait au
lac et s'est approché de la maison il
pouvait encore voir une faible lumière à
l'intérieur elle ne voyait personne
c'était seulement une lumière jaune elle
a fait le tour de la maison elle voulait
voir qui étaient à l'intérieur ça
devrait être georges d'un jour at elle
crié c'est moi sylvie personne n'a
répondu
soudain il ya eu un bruit dans la maison
ok j'en ai assez et georges d'ici vie ce
n'est plus drôle cbi s'est approché de
la porte et l'a ouverte
là elle a vu une chose à laquelle elle
ne s'attendait pas tous ses amis étaient
là
beaucoup de gens étaient dans la maison
sa mère d'autres membres de sa famille
ses amis marie et vernis
et d'autres amis sylvie a crié sa mère
te voilà
bonjour à être at elle dit mais qu'est
ce qu'il se passe ici on va te raconter
à soit toi sylvie cette assise sur le
lit
qu'est ce qui s'est passé a dit sylvie
finalement les gens se sont assis autour
d'elle l'air préoccupé
personne n'a répondu et papa il est où
at il dit à sa mère il travaille il
viendra plus tard quelqu'un peut me dire
ce qui se passe
sa mère s'est levé et lui a dit nous
pensons qu'une bête à enlever georges
dans la forêt comment comment vous savez
qu'on a vu une créature georges a envoyé
un message avec son téléphone portable
il a dit qu'il avait besoin dead après
ça son portable n'a plus fonctionné
sylvie ne comprenez toujours rien et à
dire pourquoi vous êtes tous ici parce
qu'on va chercher georges
maintenant oui maintenant ok a brief
excepte from his book
domitalia match jean louis droz tori
spelling est tout sauf un canapé engadin
ford france
[Musique]